the chichi science show clips
exactly and i mean
as you mentioned earlier one of the
reasons that um you created the fasting
mimicking diet is to kind of um avoid
some of the more deleterious effects of
doing water any fasting which could lead
to malnourishment and one thing that i
find quite interesting and you had a
paper i think came out in 2019 which is
how fasting can influence the gut
microbiome and obviously the gut
microbiome feeds off like fiber that we
consume in our diets and so and
sometimes in my head the thought of
doing a water only fasting makes me
think what's going on with my the gut
microbiome have they got any foods and
so obviously
you showed in
that study i believe it was looking at
how fmd kids alleviate symptoms of
inflammatory bowel syndrome and so i was
just wondering like to what extent do
you think some of the benefits of fmd
are being mediated by the gut microbiome
and what part do you think they play in
the whole process
yeah so um
the original idea because walford was um
and lots of people that i work with were
always fans of either vegan diets or
pescatarian diet and these longevity
areas around the world you know the
okinawa
so i i thought from the very beginning i
want to melt i don't want to do a fast
mimicking diet with any ingredient i
want to do a fasting diet mimicking diet
with the ingredients the longest lived
people in the world eat all the time
and and
you know
you could have argued with me it's like
that makes no sense because you just
giving it to them for five days once in
a while while you
do it with the use meat use red meat use
uh
um use lard right
uh use animal products yeah
but i thought no i wanna i think
eventually we're gonna see benefits from
using the right ingredients and you know
that paper was one of the first ones
showing that water only fasting actually
made the gut more of mice more leaky
right and it makes sense right because
the mice after not having food for a
while they start
breaking down lots of cells they don't
need as much right so if you have just
water you can break down the gut and the
leakiness increases
and
but with the fasting making dye which
contains a lot of vegetable a lot of
prebiotic
um we didn't see that right so there's
probably enough food in the gut plus
this feeding of of these
lactobacillus bifida bacteria etc it was
probably sufficient that we saw this big
expansion these protective
microbes
and um
and we don't know but i mean there's
lots of papers that are now are
suggesting that
yes if you go from
whatever 15 to 60
protective
bacteria species then
you you could be expected to have
benefits for inflammatory bowel disease
or general inflammation of the gut so
now we have you know number of clinical
trials that that are looking at exactly
that
uh stanford is actually now taking the
lead in doing the uh the studies so
we'll see what happens but um
but now we're sort of combining this
idea of the fasting with the idea of
feeding
the microbes right so fasting while
feeding
um
and and i think that that's very
important and also the pulse fasting
feeding is important so what would fad
during the fast but it was also fad
after the fast that is probably driving
you know the microbes one way or another
so if you eat a steak
um this could be
killing a lot of the effects
of the the five days of the of the vegan
diet right so
um yeah so that's why we we also think
that at least 24 hours past the fmd
should be
lots of vegetables maybe a little bit of
fish
and that's it you know and make like
cereals a little bit of fish and lots of
vegetables
you